Narrator: Can you find
the seal on the ball?
It's hiding behind those blocks.
What about the rubber band?
That's over by the alligator.
Does this look familiar?
These photos are from
the "I Spy" book series,
introduced in 1992, and
there's a good chance
that either you or your
kids have read them.
But did you know that all of these images
were created with real objects?
The magic and mystery within these books
is directly tied to the imagination of
the photographer behind them,
Walter Wick.
Walter Wick: My name is Walter Wick.
I am a photo-illustrator,
and I've been doing
that for I don't know
how long, since 1991.
Narrator: Before "I Spy,"
Walter was a commercial
photographer in New York City.
One of his clients was Games magazine,
which created puzzles and
activities for each issue.
But how did Walter end
up working on "I Spy"?
One day around 1980, Walter
was cleaning up his studio
and he decided to take a
picture of the stray nuts
and bolts he had lying around.
Walter used that photo
to promote his work,
which is how the author
Jean Marzollo saw it.
Walter: I got a call from
Jean Marzollo to do a poster
for her magazine, which
is called Let's Find Out.
It's a kindergarten magazine.
Narrator: An editor at Scholastic Books
saw that poster and
asked if Jean and Walter
wanted to make a
search-and-find children's book.
Jean would write the rhymes,
and Walter would create the images.
Walter: And I said sure,
and that's how it started.
Narrator: But perhaps what made the books
so successful was how
realistic they looked.
The combination of props, sets,
and lighting created an immersive scene.
Originally, Walter used
a large-format camera
to photograph each scene.
This created huge 8-by-10 negatives.
Which was ideal, because
the larger image size
captured a ton of detail.
Then around 2004, Walter
switched to digital.
He now uses a Canon 5D.
But Walter was quick to point out
that the camera does
little of the real work.
Because it just sits there
while Walter spends
weeks building the sets.
Walter's studio is filled
with the props and materials
he uses to build these incredible images,
like blocks, buttons,
toys, and even pine cones.
Walter: I would hide the objects
as I would build the shot.
I wouldn't really think about
hiding the objects first.
I would create the shot, make
a list of the hidden objects,
send it to Jean, and then
she would write the rhyme.
Narrator: Each scene is
arranged very carefully
around a central idea or theme,
like nature, antiques, or school.
Walter: One of the problems
with photo illustrations
is you're limited by
what you have available.
The higher-level concepts
became harder and harder
and harder to do, though, as I went on,
because I didn't want to repeat myself.
Narrator: But "I Spy"
isn't the only series
Walter has worked on.
He's also the author and photo-illustrator
of the "Can You See What I
See?" books and "Hey, Seymour!"
Which follow the search-and-find
style of "I Spy."
In order to make these scenes a reality,
Walter works with assistants,
fabricators, and model-makers.
For "Can You See What I
See?: Toyland Express,"
Walter's team built a
toy train from scratch
because they needed to show it
being assembled throughout the story.
Each photo can take
anywhere from a couple days
to several weeks to create.
The attention to detail is part
of what makes these photos so compelling.
And Walter continues to capture
the imagination of readers today.
His newest book, "A Ray of Light,"
is a science book that
uses beautiful photos
to illustrate the properties of light.
It's a companion to Walter's
1997 book "A Drop of Water."
Walter: I've always wanted
to do the book on light.
I was a little afraid of it.
Because as much as I work
with light and I know light,
I was a little afraid to
try and to explain the inner
workings of it to young readers.
But I finally did that.
Narrator: The "I Spy" and
"Can You See What I See?"
books have over 45
million copies in print.
The care and attention to
detail put into every frame
still resonates with readers today.
Walter: I was very surprised
from the very beginning
how intensely kids
looked at my photographs,
so I just put that same
intensity back into making them.
Narrator: Imagination and the sense
of discovery are timeless.